this is the real experience actors are
often asked to slim down for a role
but for george clooney a drastic weight
loss landed him in the hospital
jennifer lawrence couldn't wait to ditch
her ballerina diet
while tom holland was excited to get
thin for a new role
here are the stars who had to lose a ton
of weight for the big screen
you know every single time how did i
become this person daniel radcliffe had
to look like he lost 35
pounds to play yossi ginsburg an israeli
adventurist who was missing for three
weeks and survived by eating just one
egg a day
rumors flew that the actor also only ate
one egg a day to try and get into the
survivor's mindset
but his actual daily diet consisted of
only one chicken breast and a protein
bar for two weeks before shooting
hello george clooney was so
invested in losing 25 pounds for
midnight sky that he ended up making
himself sick
what are we gonna do four days before he
was due to start filming the actor was
rushed to hospital with severe stomach
pains
and was diagnosed with pancreatitis it
looks like the cause was all the working
out he was doing
while not eating properly but he did get
the body needed to play the ailing
arctic scientist
goodbye to star in jungle land charlie
hunnam had to look considerably leaner
than we're used to seeing him in sons of
anarchy
you don't know what you're talking about
the actor lost about 30 pounds and even
shopped at flea markets to help
round out his character's wardrobe but
hunnam's no stranger to weight loss
for a role in the lost city of zee he
starred opposite robert pattinson and
they were both hungry the entire time
they even argued every day over who had
eaten fewer eggs before filming
like look at that someone got bitten in
the neck
lily collins lost 20 pounds to star into
the bone
as a young woman suffering from an
eating disorder collins was initially
scared of losing that much weight
since she'd also suffered from
disordered eating yes
thankfully she did it all under the
supervision of a nutritionist
while taking supplements and in the end
she was thankful to create a
conversation around the taboo topic
finished tom holland had to gain some
muscle to play everyone's favorite
neighborhood spider-man
but for his new film cherry well i just
been seeing on the news
he had to lose as much weight as
possible he enrolled in a six-week boot
camp where he was constantly working out
though he was excited to accept the
challenge of slimming down for a role
running every day was his least favorite
part and we
can't say we blame him just trying to do
something good and here i am
considering henry cavill does his own
stunts most of his workouts to prepare
himself for starring in the witcher were
done in the weight room
to play geralt cavill had to look fairly
slim
even as he packed on the muscles he did
fasted cardio six days a week while
filming to burn fat and boost his
metabolism
and the body that resulted is one we're
more than happy to see on netflix
this really helps with the sword
fighting aspect
preparing for red sparrow was the first
time jennifer lawrence ever went on a
serious diet
lawrence was also told to lose weight
for the hunger games but refused
to develop a believable ballerina body
though the actress worked with a
professional dance coach
and trained six days a week thankfully
director francis lawrence knew how hard
it would be to cut calories
and filmed all the ballerina scenes
first so jayla could go back to being a
foodie
can i at least finish my teeth mila
kunis lost 20 pounds in just five months
to play a ballerina in black swan
i'm lilly she only ate 1 200 calories a
day and trained in ballet for five hours
each and every day for three months
straight
she ended up weighing only 95 pounds
while filming
but once the project wrapped she happily
went right back to pizza and milkshakes
so kumail nanjiani had a major
transformation after he got cast in the
mcu
the actor added daily workouts to his
regime and cut out pizza
doughnuts refined sugar and carbs for a
whole year to take on a roll in the
eternals
i get a bag of sugar snap peas and i eat
them
nanjiani felt it was his responsibility
to get into shape as the first pakistani
superhero in hollywood
but says it would have been impossible
without all the time and resources given
to him by marvel
you know every single time how did i
become this person in the hbo miniseries
i know this much is true mark ruffalo
plays twin brothers of pretty different
sizes
he lost some weight to play the smaller
of the twins and shot all those scenes
first
then he spent five weeks gaining 30
pounds to play the heavier brother
the result is an innovative tv series
where the twins both look
the same while also being completely
different people
yeah what sure anything chris pratt
dropped 60 pounds to go from andy and
parks and rec
to marvel's star-lord you can buy two
candies two
frat had the help of a personal trainer
and nutritionist and ate 4 000 calories
a day to build muscle
he added lots of water to his daily
routine as well as constant exercise to
both slim down and bulk up
which was completely different from the
couch potato habits he developed when he
put on weight to play andy
that sounds about right to transform
into a sailor
stranded at sea chris hemsworth had to
shed over 30 pounds of that thor
physique
for which he had originally gained 20
pounds of pure muscle
by the time they began to film out at
sea around the canary islands
the actor was consuming just 500
calories a day
some days to 500 calories a day and
which is nothing you know it's a piece
of fish and a bit of rice
which is three to four thousand calories
less than what he was used to
making him understandably a little moody
hey hey take it easy ned leads
peter parker's best friend is going to
look pretty different in the upcoming
spider-man film
actor jacob betalon shed a ton of weight
to prepare for the currently untitled
marvel movie
and he might have a much larger role to
play betilan is a filipino descent
and wants to use his role in the mcu as
a stepping stone for people of color
hoping that his transformation can help
catapult ned from sidekick
to superhero i'm fine okay don't worry
beyonce lost about 20 pounds using a
10-day all-liquid diet for her role in
dream girls
the diet doesn't permit solid foods but
includes things like lemon juice and
maple syrup
but beyonce is no stranger to crash
diets which she doesn't recommend you
try at home
she ate just 1 200 calories a day while
filming austin powers
and lost 20 pounds for her coachella
performance
small weight harry melling wasn't told
to lose weight for any specific role
but it wasn't until after he made a
major transformation that he outgrew his
reputation as dudley from harry potter
in fact fans barely ever recognize him
anymore and he's gone on to star in
shows like the queen's gambit and movies
like the devil all the time
his weight loss actually started while
he was still filming harry potter
so he had to wear a fat suit in deathly
hallows part one
yeah it was amazing playing someone
struggling with an eating disorder was a
bit too
close to home for zoey kravitz when she
starred in the road within
the actress is very vocal about her
struggles and how she ended up weighing
less than 90 pounds by the time they
started filming
she became sick and experienced thyroid
issues due to malnourishment
and encourages others with similar
issues to be open and seek support
you know i was once a teenager and
that's a really really hard time
to star in pompeii kit harington did a
four hour a day workout for seven days a
week
while eating only 1800 calories
the diet was designed to burn fat while
also building muscle
since the film was trying to look as
realistic as possible they
even used real weapons in the fight
scenes so kitt's warrior body had to be
entirely believable
training sort of six times a week
putting being put on a
fierce diet for a role that won him an
oscar watkin phoenix lost an astounding
52 pounds
but was overseen by a doctor the entire
time to make sure he did it safely
still he admits that losing that much
weight and cutting back on food made him
go
mad but also made it even easier to play
the joker
his daily diet wasn't much more than an
apple lettuce and some green beans
but he was so hungry and unhealthy that
even walking up stairs became difficult
i felt like i could move my body in ways
that i hadn't been able to
before matthew mcconaughey was all over
the news for his 47 pound weight loss to
star in dallas buyers club
first time ever had to do it he lost the
weight in four months thanks to a
nutritionist
and spent a lot of time chewing on ice
instead of eating
he lost 3.5 pounds a week but there were
long-term effects
he says he depleted some of his body's
strength permanently because of his
drastic transformation
you can your features can come back if
you rush it they can come back in odd
ways
so i very slowly put the weight back on
to play fantine in les miserables anne
hathaway had to drop
25 pounds in just two weeks and admitted
it took a toll on her body and mind
that weight loss was not a long-term
good thing for my health she lost 10
pounds using a strict cleanse before
filming began
and then lost another 15 pounds by
eating just two squares of dried oatmeal
paste per day
but she felt anxious while filming and
regretted the decision to lose so much
weight
even after winning an oscar there are so
many people
whose generosity and support is the
reason that i'm standing here right now
which of these transformations shocked
you the most let us know in the comment
section down below
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to our channel for more
thanks for watching
you